did you never have that on the kids as a
kid just like some a game or something
that you played so many times that you
could just like recite it from memory
no never not your sight here i probably
played savanch but never saying i could
recite
from memory but are you the kind of
person who remembers song lyrics easily
no not at all i i actually cannot
remember song lyrics without looking at
the sheet right and even then it's like
it'll last like a day yeah because it's
really interesting there's like there's
two types of people where there's like
there's ones who are like you can listen
to a song once and you just like
miraculously just remember how the
lyrics go and then there are people who
are just like i could listen to this
song 50 times
and it's like i'll recognize the lyrics
if someone tells me
but i can't recite it okay so i had this
like i had this like realization the
other day um because you know i've
obviously i've obviously given connor a
lot of [ __ ] for like hearing the beeps
and the boobs yeah um and then i just
had this realization that
i think i listened to this i think i
listen to music like beeps and boops as
well right because
okay like lyrics mean nothing to me like
like it's it's so it's so weird yeah
it's so weird right where like i listen
to a song and
if lyrics aren't there right i i feel
like something's missing because i do
think lyrics is a part of the song but
to me lyrics are almost like another
instrument instrument to me it's it's so
weird it's so weird where where like i
don't listen to what they're saying and
even like even if you can take a song
that i love and you lay the lyrics out
in front of me and i'm just like i've
never heard this song in my life like
what is what is this song well i would
argue that the best
artists and the best singers and the
best bands i guess can yeah as you said
use their voice as an instrument
but then if you want to read into the
lyrics the lyrics are also profound
where unfortunately
very few artists can do that right where
it's either like you either concentrate
fully on the lyrics to be like here's a
deep poetic meaning behind it
understanding this are you saying the
voice is a part of the song is that what
you're saying yeah
yeah no [ __ ] yeah it's like another but
but you know there are a lot of artists
who don't see it that way and they just
like it's like it also depends on how
the songs mix but like some artists you
hear and it's just like oh
i wish i could hear the instruments
because it's just being drowned out by
the singing
but like have you ever like
properly listened to the lyrics of a
song and it's like change the way you
think about a song because you probably
actually read into it
like the the new weekend album is really
good but like if you just actually
listen to what you're saying it's
depressing as [ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah so
that rarely ever you're like vibing
you're like dude this song is so good
and he's like i'm [ __ ] depressed
and [ __ ] is going wrong and it's like
yeah [ __ ] it's so good
wait what do you say
and then you like listen it and it's
like wait hold on
he did why
yeah i can't i can't even get to that
moment because it like it it's really
weird but like sometimes if there's like
a disconnect between how the song makes
me feel versus what the lyrics are
saying i always like go i always go
towards what the song makes me feel
yeah
and it's it's so it's so weird because i
don't know how much of this is [ __ ]
well thanks to the beeps and boots yeah
it's it's that that's it i hear the
beeps in the boobs the beeps and the
boobs make me feel something and that's
what i feel towards the song that i
hardly ever listen to lyrics at all
because it never changes how i feel
towards the song
it's it's so weird
you guys are literally that type of
people who would make a [ __ ] art
buzzfeed article being like top 10 songs
that have a dark meaning
engineering
i hear the [ __ ] the music it comes in
and it just comes in like a
like a like a like a i don't know like a
[ __ ] graph in my head
it comes out the thing is i get that i
totally get that but i feel it like i i
do have emotions towards it yeah of
course but i don't give a [ __ ] what he's
talking about right i'm like i'm just
intaking the noise and the noise either
makes me feel something or it doesn't
yeah which is why i think for a lot of
songs where there is like a stark
contrast between how the song makes you
feel versus how the lyrics make you feel
yeah is what is like a bigger whiplash
for people like you guys right like
where it's like oh what the [ __ ] live i
don't know how i want to preface live it
is different there definitely is a lot
more to it whenever yeah
yeah recorded album yeah i feel like
that's why i find it so easy to you know
listen to a lot of japanese music or a
lot of like music in a language that i
don't understand yeah because it's
they're probably you know i have no idea
what the lyrics they are spitting most
of the time but you know this part of me
is like i feel i feel the emotion
yeah i i feel the emotion that they're
singing right now oh yeah i kind of get
it even though i probably don't get it i
feel like i get it i can't tell you like
like i'd say 90 of anime openings the
lyrics are depressing as [ __ ]
but
like just weaves that are kind of like
man
which is you know fine it's it's cool i
i that's what i find really interesting
though about people who can do that
right and it's like you know it's the
reason why i feel that in and of itself
like that discovery of like when people
find out this really like bright and
like colorful and like very positive
sounding song actually has a really
[ __ ] dark meaning and then you know
and it's that realization of like oh
[ __ ] i just got played yeah
because i wasn't listening to the lyrics
right like yeah that's why i'm like
because we've we like had this idea to
do a music three by three for like ages
and i've like loki actually been
[ __ ] myself
why because like
one of the things one of the mediums i
find hardest to [ __ ] explain
is music because i literally are just
like um i mean this song this sounds
good this song made me feel things um
and i just really like it um and and
people are like oh did you know the
meaning of that song i'm like i have no
idea the meaning of that song yeah yeah
but it made me feel things yeah they
make you feel things
welcome to the beeps and the boobs
ladies i thought you were i thought you
were on my team
i feel betrayed
welcome to the beeps and boots oh glass
glass vehicle i felt absolutely betrayed
god damn it the music episode would be
joey talking for two hours yeah yeah
right and then
i like
that's why i almost don't want to do it
because i think i'd probably just make a
video on my own you're going to carry
the episode yeah exactly which might be
the shortest days episode of all time
yeah probably like 40 minutes in we're
like and that's it yeah all right thanks
for joining us do you have an example of
like a song where the lyrics um where
you where the where you found more like
reading into the lyrics and the deeper
meaning of that song as opposed to just
listening to you know the initial beats
the beeps and the boobs the beeps and
the boobs i mean like like i'll go into
pink floyd the wall well yes
but also like yeah i think there's like
a lot of like artists that you know
again it's like it's it's that
brilliance of you know using the lead
singer as just like an instrument where
it's like if you're not listening to the
lyrics or anything like that it still
sounds great and it's still like sticky
in your head but then you've but then
one day you're like you know i've
listened to this song like three or four
times but i've never actually read the
lyrics let me read into the lyrics and
then you read into and you know a lot of
it's very like poetic and you know it
completely changes the way you view that
song like you know [ __ ] like great ex
like you know [ __ ] you know you know
turning japanese you know that song yeah
no
turn in japanese i think i'm doing it
that song's about masturbation oh yeah
but no one knows it because no one
[ __ ] reads into the lyrics they just
see they just hear that
and i was like oh yeah i love that song
this is what turning japanese is about
yeah it's about masturbation i i've
never heard of these songs like how
pumped up kicks is about school
shootings right i know that one i know i
know like when people first discovered
that they were like oh my god i've been
[ __ ] debated right but it's catchy as
[ __ ] it's catchy as [ __ ]
it's like i don't know i find that to be
like as someone who also writes music
that is so much [ __ ] harder than it
looks yeah i know i can imagine and i
feel bad that i don't or i have the
inability to appreciate it because like
but i feel that's fine because like i
feel with those kinds of songs they're
taking into account how it sounds first
and then they think about the meaning
afterwards right yeah i think the only
exception is with like rap music you
know where it is just like basically
just lyrical poems to a beat right so
that's where i actually have more of an
understanding or like or like an image
in my head of oh man these lyrics go
[ __ ] hard but right yeah they do
listen to the lyrics yeah but try it
right yeah but like most of the times i
actually see the lyric sheets and it
almost like it almost like transforms it
that to a point where i don't even
recognize the song anymore it's always
like separate from the song itself it's
so weird
if someone can explain this to me like
i'm like super curious uh because i've
just i i think i just i i'm incapable of
like getting the meaning of lyrics as
i'm listening to the song at the same
time i reckon has anything to do with
the fact that i'm the only musical
trained one out of the three of us
probably probably appreciate it more
yeah maybe to me it's all noise right i
like it
yeah but it's nice i mean i i i can play
musical instruments but i've never been
like professionally trained right right
i think that's just what it is right
like i feel it's just because you've
been trained to listen to music in a
different way that you can just perceive
these smaller points that other people
would just perceive as just the beeps
and the boobs right i mean to me like
it's like it's like people who you know
go to a gallery and look at art right
it's like you've clearly just been like
a lot of them have just been trained to
look at this thing in a completely
different way that you otherwise would
have a very hard time grasping right
like you know you you go to an art
gallery with an art critic and they'd be
like yes i love the the flow and the the
texture and the feelings that i get from
it it's making me feel this way and the
average person looking to be like oh
yeah i like the color red as well you
know like
it's just i think it's just based on how
you're trained yeah like like to me like
you know i can play musical instruments
and um stuff like that but i've never
like
i've i've never thought i was i've never
like studied music theory or anything
like that so like when i like wrote
songs before it was more like
c major sound nice or something or
something like that i don't like you
know
her chords sound nice that was just like
my process you know d come after scene
musically trained
musically trained
god damn
but yeah at this rate i don't know if
we'll ever actually
say i've listened to everything i like
everything a lot of others i'm like i
like this one album
[Music]
you know like arctic monkeys i like a
lot but yeah like not every album you
know right right and i get it you want
to be experimental do your thing but i
don't know how i can sit there and be
like this is one of my favorite artists
by the way this one album [ __ ] i don't
like yeah well no i think i think that's
a valentine's day i think i mean i mean
like
a lot of my favorite artists have a [ __ ]
album or two
like i don't know if i'm a anomaly in
this as well but i don't normally listen
to albums as a whole
i'm like shooting myself finding like
think of nine albums because i'm like
how many like four albums have i [ __ ]
listened to it we'll do it eventually
yeah we'll do it eventually i gotta
figure out how to like talk about music
first yeah you guys deal with that
and then when you guys already come back
and then we can do it like i feel like
he was trying to say something with this
song i could feel it i don't know what
it was exactly but i feel like i like
these words in this song he said he felt
it coming many times and i believe he
did feel it coming oh i was definitely
coming as well
oh my god